[Music]  my name is Ben Aaron Austin I'm a  self-made millionaire at an offshore  boating champion  my boats have won hundreds of races oh  yeah  they've also moved 100 million pounds of  cocaine through Miami  you can't say Miami without sake then  how about Big Bear mr. vice president we  just got some government money King  Saints girlfriend you gotta be kidding  me  he's got two wives and an army yeah I  don't know that that's illegal we busted  a lot of drug dealers driving airboats  my boats boats manufacture major company  for your family Betty remember who you  are where you came from  I don't know anybody anything  so what are your plans like usual to win  you know a renegade  you'll do your part  [Music]  you  you